Nicole is the mother of Madison bul
thank
you good morning M if you could please
State your full name for the record
Nicole F thank you and is there
something you wish to state to the court
this morning yes I do thank you you make
your seat
ma'
morning your
honor Madison Baldwin a name that most
didn't know prior to this horrific act
but now a name that everyone has come to
love a name that has brought so much Joy
to the
World your
honor I
know you haven't had the privilege to
know
her only of what what you've heard she
is an old soul
wiser Beyond her years at only 17 she
has taught me more than I could ever
thank her
for having her young myself she made me
the mother I am today she gave me the
courage to be
stronger a few key things about
Madison was her laughter contagious
smile intelligence passion kindness
Fearless drive and
determination she is the light when you
need it most when the world gets dark
she's the
stars that small Beacon of light that is
so far to see but up close burns like
wild
fire at times I catch myself missing
these characteristics worried that I
might forget them but then I realized
she's here Madison lives in all of us
her Legacy remains her kindness
continues now and forever she will
always be the heartbeat of our
family on November 30th 2021 is a day
that has forever changed my life it
burns into my body like a cigarette
burn enough to scar but always a
constant
reminder the day I found out that my
daughter's life was
taken a life that was still so young and
full of
life after that day she became a
statistic
a victim a planned Act of
tragedy How Could my daughter be
summarized in such intrusive manner how
could these now be her
associations I would like you to know
that these accusations are
false I would I will not allow her name
to be followed by the phrase Oxford
shooting
victim she will be remembered by her
name a name that is loved
unconditionally one that is has no
hidden
remark the strong name we gave her
madison when I received word that the
school was under attack my daughter had
already been gone for over an
hour this I didn't know while driving
into a designated area pretty much on
autopilot waiting for the
unknown as I paced the Meyers asking
where my daughter was all I received was
blank
stairs as the remaining kids re re
reunited with their families we were
left there in silence waiting for the
answer answers that we are still waiting
for next thing I hear can the family of
Madison Baldwin follow
me as I walked into the room I felt this
chill come across to my body so cold
that I felt it in my bones I pleaded not
to go in but following command the words
we
heard
were I don't have good news on these
three children they are
deceased the sheer blunt statement could
destroy you to the core I was completely
paralyzed I felt every scream that I ca
that came from my body I felt every
breath I took was fading my mind was in
a state of dementia and then my body
drops to the
floor we were literally suffocating
suffocating together in
disbelief replaying those words in my
head within seconds I thought did I hear
them right I was definitely
misinformed the sobs came from a deep
part in me SE tears soaked the cold
floor I laid on I managed a few calls
but conversations I've blocked out
leaving for the substation I stared out
the window looking for for her but
replaying those words in my head my mind
and heart were literally in two
different
places the rest of the night was excuse
after excuse on why I couldn't take I
couldn't be taken to my daughter I
needed to see her I needed to prove that
the information was not meant for me but
all I was
offered was a table the next day at the
medical examiner's office to identify
her getting back back home felt like
forever I had to tell her 11-year-old
sister at the time that her best friend
was
gone Payton screams will forever haunt
me and when she asked me that simple
question why as a mom I didn't have the
answer the next morning I was on my way
to prove somebody wrong at the medical
examiner's office in my head it wasn't
going to be her as I walked down the
corridor I entered into a room
with a steel door and a small glass
window I couldn't move my feet I
couldn't get close enough to look but
when I remembered I was there to prove
somebody
wrong I looked through the glass my
scream sh should have shattered it my
daughter's lifeless body was laying on a
cold metal gurnie I remember her hand
laying out from underneath the sheet and
her fingernails were
blue blood smeared in her hair and they
made sure I saw her from a side that was
more acceptable for a grieving
mother that was not my daughter Madison
was far from
lifeless as I banged on the door
demanding to touch her I lost my ability
to stand I was dragged away from her I
was not allowed to touch my own daughter
I was not allowed to hold her hand and
just let her know I was
there it's a feeling that no parent
should ever feel but that's my baby I
deserved the right to be with her but I
was not allowed instead I was dragged
away from her screaming like a toddler
saying profanities in the most ignorant
way that is when I realized I could no
longer deny it I didn't want to admit I
was wrong I didn't want to visualize a
moment without her I didn't want to
believe she was gone but it hit me like
a semi TR I knew her dreams were no
longer the future but only dreams
your honor I thank you for the
dedication to this infuriating act I
admire your knowledge of the law and the
stance on to listening to all keeping
your composure and consistency
throughout this sentencing I thank you
for the clear representation of your
courtroom I thank you for the countless
hours that has that this has taken from
you and your family's life to give the
best possible judgment I thank you for
being a human
being to the prosecution and
Advocates Karen Mark David and countless
others I thank you for the constant
efforts to keep my daughter's legacy
alive the righteous hours the rigorous
hours that have consumed
you your non-stop actions to make sure
all facts are given appropriately your
compassion for our
family Jen my
Advocate and
others Advocates I thank you for picking
me up on some of my worst days Days in
moments that I thought my life was not
valuable keeping me sane during every
moment even when weakness was at its
worst you all have remembered my
daughter and kept her spirit alive in
the most PR presious
manner thank you for taking away from
your life to get Justice for her life
and lastly thank you for doing the
unthinkable the tragic the raw the
vulnerable and infuriating moments when
I know it breaks you inside to make sure
that we are slightest the slightest bit
okay to make sure we continue that we
remember and that we keep fighting for
justice
to the waste that took my daughter's
life that name will never come out of my
mouth that life will cease to exist to
me and just like trash it will be
forgotten so while the attention that he
has been seeking for this horrendous
crime you will get no reaction from
me but again this is the life he
chose if he really wanted to make a
different outcome he would continue to
he wouldn't continue to make the excuses
he does
now the suffering will come when he
least expects it the regret will consume
you as you sit alone with the only voice
only voices in your head guilt would eat
away at your soul this might not happen
tomorrow next year or 10 years but it
will happen as you get older you will
realize the path you've chosen and it
will haunt
you just like the idol that you admire
so much
both of you forgotten in the
system and when these emotions flood
into your body like you're bleeding out
no one will be there to save you no one
will forgive you your hand will not will
no longer be held as you claim in sanity
your outb Outburst for attention will go
unnoticed no one will love you and no
one will come as I don't wish death upon
you that would be too
easy I hope the thoughts consume you and
they replay over and over in your head
the thoughts won't stop I'm sure you
heard that paraphrase
before I hope the screams keep you up at
night and they cause real
hallucinations you won't be able to
write it on paper for the attention that
you so badly
seek those four walls become your home
suffocating and
guilt it will come I promise you I'm
happy you decided not to be a coward
that day and take your own life I much
rather you stick around to see what the
life you have chosen for what suffering
really feels like and that your
significance is not above anyone else I
truly feel sorry for you that you
thought this would be a better life
choice so your
honor I have chosen
forgiveness we live in a world where
forgiveness is not deserved but needed
forgiveness
a word that holds so much
controversy what does it really
mean to me forgiveness is an
encouragement it encourages me to
forgive the things that are out of my
control I have chosen to forgive I have
chosen to forgive for
myself and some that might seem weak or
giving in it's my new joury Journey with
Madison because honestly that is who she
was and that is what she would have
done I no longer carry that burden it
does not define me it does not F Define
her or it does not define our family I
forgive myself for the grief that at
times felt like multiple stab wounds but
managed to survive I forgive myself for
the weak moments of fear of the world
around
me the time it's taken from my family
and loved ones time I will never get
back I forgive myself for not allowing
joy and happiness in my life to reflect
and to learn I forgive myself for any
anger that raged inside me and took out
I took out on the ones I love in hopes
that this would destroy me or suffering
would be
unbearable you
failed I'm so much stronger than you and
your weakness consumes
you I don't choose to forgive the
destructive n nature that caused her
death forgiving is a choice I choose not
to forgive you for the choice you made
this is exactly what you wanted this is
not a life that I would ever want to
live what this is done is ignited the
light that I thought I lost Madison's
light your honor I hope you stamp his
faith with whatever fate that might be
to continue to live the life sentence
that he
researched that his life sentence is the
same as my life sentence I
received as a life sentence that I
cannot escape
from day by day passes I hope his life
seems more
meaningless lost and
forgotten so when my time comes and I
will never worry if our past or Fates
will ever meet again but when our true
day of judgment comes my Justice will be
served that this that his life sentence
will continue so that he may live in his
own personal prison for
eternity with no one waiting for him I
can only wish him the best on his new
life and the rep repercussions that
follow your honor as I close this
chapter and I start a new one I would
like to make one thing clear
these actions did not break me I am not
broken I am just rearranging the
pieces I am surviving each day
navigating this journey celebrating the
good and learning from the bad choosing
happiness forgiving when needed and when
it's
deserved I am
living I'm living because of my baby
girl Madison thank you thank you first
off now sorry for your loss thank you
for your statements this morning showed
a lot of strength and encourage so I
appreciate thank
you good morning sir if you could please
State your PO name for the reference for
your last name good morning my name is
Craig Schilling s i l l i n g thank you
thank you for being here sir is there a
statement that you wish to make uh yes
your honor um but before I make my
written statement I like to have a
candid moment with y'all um
to to try and directly
convey to you that this statement has
been the hardest thing I've ever written
in my
life uh you guys have the
uh condensed
version 15 minutes or
so but it took me months and months and
months and I've swam through raw
emotions trying to get this done so
thank you for letting me be here well
absolutely sir thank you I'll begin now
honorable Judge
row I am here before you today as a
direct result of the horrible crimes
that were committed back on November
30th 20 2021 the day that my son was
murdered for the longest time and for
reasons I do not care to mention here
today I did not know if I was was going
to be able to do this you see on that
day my life was torn apart and for a
while thereafter I struggled with dark
thoughts and found myself completely
lost in a seemingly Endless Sea of
raging emotions with no care as to what
happened to
me grief had consumed me and has
squeezed out every bit of joy and
happiness in my life still today it's
uncertain if I'll find my way
back the events that took place that day
have rocked three generations of my
family and has altered our future
forever these days there's not much
happiness in the
holidays birthdays and those Milestones
days don't carry with them the special
feeling they always used
to life used to flow at some sort of
Rhythm and balance and the continuity
within our family was evident there were
Gatherings vacations and funfilled
events what I feel most would deem your
typical family
situation that continuity and all that
came with it were lost on the day that
my son was
murdered like a SED electrical line the
flow was no longer there instead we
fallen into the darkness still in shock
in total disbelief over the fact that
this actually happened to
us completely blindsided we've been
carrying on with more questions than
answers and left to deal with the ders
of emotions we've never experienced
before one could venture to say that
there are no words that can accurately
describe the pain that we feel on a
daily
basis I have PT PTSD and struggle most
days to even get out of bed anxiety
stress sleepless nights and uncontrolled
emotional artbreak breaks make even the
simplest most normal things
difficult scattered thoughts raw
emotions and that uncomfortable elephant
and the room feeling I get with everyone
I interact with cause substantial
uneasiness and affect everything I
do the things I used to find enjoyment
in are no longer reliable in that
respect and are done to merely have a
feeling of something
normal golfing bowling ball games
hunting fishing camping kaying are just
a few of the activities I used to do
with Justin that seemingly will never
have the same effects on Me based solely
on the fact that he's not there to do
them with
me I've always operated on the premise
that if you get the kids into the things
that you like to do that you'll have
those things in common forever and we'll
always have a way to spend some quality
time
together even it's even if it's just for
a quick nine or an hour on the boards
blowing out a few
Pockets Father's Day forsome with my
three kids out on the link was something
I've been looking for forward to for a
long time but we'll never
have this unfair reality is something I
will never get
over day-to-day life goes on for so many
but in the clutches of grief and
heartache the difficulties are real and
has so many side
effects it almost feels like time slows
down and everything around you speeds up
it's been two years already but feels
much like yesterday I still find myself
waiting up for him to get home from
so we can get a few minutes to chat as
it was often the only time we'd have
that chance to it's unbearable to know
that he's never going to walk through
that
door never in a million years did I
think that something like this was going
to happen to me although we all know the
unfortunate real possibility that this
can happen to anyone anywhere anytime
there's absolutely no way you can
prepare yourself for this level of
pain it doesn't matter how much you
think you've prepared or how strong you
are or how big your support network is
is you
have you have this level of pain and
it's truly debilitating and it takes you
out having seen news reports and
documentaries on tragedies of this
nature I don't feel it uncommon at all
to watch in horror and disbelief that
something like this could actually
happen and I've done what I believe many
others have done on and let have
thoughts of how I might feel or act if
something like this ever happened to me
well now that it has happened I can 100%
assure you that the worst thoughts or
feelings you may have do not hold a
candle to how it actually
feels for centuries man has exploited
Thea The Fragile nature of the human
being and over the years have developed
many many ways to inflict pain torture
and kill millions and millions of of
human beings have met their Fates by way
of such
devices as we have all learned in school
there is a full spectrum of reasoning
Behind These
perversions although throughout history
those reasons have been widely
understood the sheer brutality of
Senseless violence has never sat well
with the human
psyche so we have evolved till now and
in our modern society we have
established laws and regulations to
essentially protect ourselves from
ourselves however as it seemingly always
the case there are those for reasons we
may never know who wish to defy the now
widely recogniz and greed upon state of
human decency and can continue to commit
such senseless acts of
violence in my opinion it takes a deeply
Disturbed individual to leave the
compass of basic human
decency the act of taking another human
being's life is not only exasperating
but extremely selfish and
unjust I believe that once an individual
crosses the boundaries of basic humanism
and admittingly maliciously kills
another person that IND individual
should meet the same
fate unfortunately based on the laws
that govern our land this has been
deemed inhumane and is wiely frowned
upon in modern society so in L of EX
execution I feel strongly that the
individual should never be allowed to
walk among his peers
again this is why I'm going to ask you
to lock this son of a pitch up for the
rest of his pathetic
life his blatant lack of human decency
and disturbing thoughts on life in
general do not in any way warrant a
second chance my son doesn't get a
second chance and neither should
he this individual has proven by
carrying out these heinous and
completely unnecessary acts of violence
that he should never consider be
considered fit to rejoin a society that
despises this exact
Behavior his very name should be
condemned recognized only by by his
cowardly vile and malicious Defiance of
human
law now with all that being
said I'd like to direct my comments
toward this disgusting individual that I
speak
of he sits across the room for me at
this very moment dressed in
Orange
emotionless although I'm sure he may
have a half-baked idea of just what I'd
like to do to him I'm not quite sure he
has adequately envisioned the exact
nature of this
idea I'd really like an opportunity to
physically show him how much pain he has
caused me and my family but in a
civilized society governed by complex
laws such as ours this type of display
is not
permitted but you can rest assured you
piece of
shit that baby bird screams would pale
in comparison to the screams that you
would exude if I were only able to show
you but luckily for you they won't let
me so I will hope hope with every bit of
hope I have left that with every passing
thought or memory you have about what
you've done you remember my statement
and take time to imagine it happening
and recognize it in the worst way
possible I've tried to put myself in
your
shoes and over and over tried to imagine
what could have possibly been so
horrible in your life to have caused you
to commit these
crimes I actually thought long and hard
and can come up with no logical EXP
ation the fact is that what you did was
reprehensible and completely
unnecessary you see we use things called
words to convey our thoughts and our
concerns and our
opinions sometimes those words we
share with Excuse me those time
sometimes those who we share our words
with don't hear them or choose to not
listen but this is no reason to throw a
tantrum and do the wrong thing
you simply have to speak
louder and to more people until you get
the results you
desire life is not easy in any sense of
the word it often feels cruel and unfair
but you what you have obviously
overlooked is the fact that life is the
most precious gift each and every one of
us receive and you have completely
wasted
yours you said you wanted to be
remembered as a person who committed the
biggest shooting in Michigan history and
this may be true but I will have it
entered on file at this time on this day
for the world to know forever that Ethan
Crumbley should be remembered as the
biggest coward in in Michigan history an
individual who unfairly prays upon
unsuspecting and helpless lives without
the courage to meet their same fate a
truly detestable and ignominious excuse
of human
being now my last words for you before I
conclude is that I truly hope your new
roommates welcome you in properly and
show you the kind of treatment you can
only get on the inside as it's clearly
all you've ever wanted and in my and is
my hope that there is some kind of pain
involved I also think that as you rot
away lamenting over your wasted life you
should take time to ponder the fact that
all you though you may have taken four
lives the selfless gesture of organ
donation by my son saved at least five
lives thus overshadowing your delusions
of grandeur and effectively nullifying
all that you feel you've
accomplished do in that for a while and
maybe you'll realize that as long as
there are good people in the world
willing to selflessly give of themselves
to help others evil will never
Triumph my final thoughts are directed
towards everyone else it is with every
bit of my heart that I offer all who
have helped my family over the course of
the last couple years the sincerest
thank
you the sheer magnitude of
humanitarianism and good will that came
in from all over the world has been
humbling and has gone a long way to
showing me there is still good out
there I strongly believe that it resides
within each and every one of us that it
is our responsibility as human beings to
let our goodness shine onto everyone we
interact with whether we like them or
not because the way we treat each other
both directly and indirectly affects the
lives of more people than you can
imagine not to mention it's simply
easier to
do I beg of you all please be kind to
one another and P your energy towards
walking the path of the righteous and do
your part to help eliminate these types
of
tragedies thank you for listening this
morning I wish you all a very BL